الأسرة الحاكمة للعالم
، يسيطرون على القوة العالمية
، هم الأيادي الخفية التي تحكم القبضة على الاقتصاد في العالم،
وبذلك هم من يسيطرون على السياسة
لكن من خلف الكواليس،
لهم القدرة على رفع دول وإسقاط أخرى،
هم من عائلة يهودية ألمانية
ولكنهم ليسو كأي عائلة،
فهم يملتكون نصف ثروت العالم من ذهب وألماس
وعملات صعبة وكل ماهو غالٍ ونفيسٍ على هذه الأرض،
(أنبياء المال)
هم يقرضون الدول الأموال والذهب
مما يجعل لهم هيمنة على تلك الدول
وعلى سياساتها وقراراتها
ومن ضمنها دول عظمى
كأمريكا وبريطانيا وروسيا...
فاطلق عليهم العديد من الألقاب
ومنها أنبياء المال،
وأما لقب العائله "روتشيلد"
فهو يعني "الدرع الأحمر"،
في إشارة إلى "الدرع" الذي ميز باب قصر مؤسس العائلة
في فرانكفورت في القرن السادس
وفيما يخص الإقامة ومكان عيشهم
فهم يعيشون في جزيرة مهجورة وبعيدة
كل البعد عن الأعين و العالم الخارجي
ولا أحد يعلم مكان هذه الجزيرة إلى يومنا هذا
وقبل أن نتكلم أكثر عن عائلة "روتشيلد"
العائله الأغنى في التاريخ
(عائلة روتشيلد)
ملوك المال والسندات،
إنه لقب يطلق على أغنى عائلة عرفها التاريخ،
وتمتلك هذه العائلة وحدها حاليا نصف ثروة العالم،
بما يعادل (500) تريليون دولار والتريليون هو مليون مليون .
إنها عائلة (Rothschild) أو (روثتشايلد) اليهودية،
وهى من أصول ألمانية تملك (البنك الدولي) بالوراثة أباً عن جد،
وتتحكم فى سعر الذهب بالعالم،
اليوم تخفض سعره، وغداً ترفعه بضغطة زر واحدة،
والبنك الدولي هو الآمر الناهي للبنوك المركزية بالعالم،
والذي هو حق موروث لعائلة (روثتشايلد).
ويلقب المصرفيون هذه العائلة بلقب (موني ماستر)
أو (أنبياء المال والسندات).
وتكمن سعادت هذه العائلة في الحروب
لأنها تزيد من ثروتهم،
و يخافون من السلام الذى يشكل لهم ركودا ماليا!
ويعيش أفراد العائلة بجزيرة مجهولة،
وقد حاول كثير من الباحثين الوصول لرأس هرم العائلة
أو كبيرها لكن في النهاية يصلون الى طريق مسدود !
لكن هذا الغموض لم يمنع الصحفيين والباحثين وراء الأسرار
عن تلقف وتتبع أسرار هذه العائلة،
وتوصل بعضهم وفقا لما قاله موقع شارل أيوب
إلى بعض المعلومات عن العائلة،
منها أن أقرب رئيس أمريكي لهم هو بوش الأب،
وأكثر دولة تزعجهم (الصين).
قد يرى البعض أن أمريكا أو بريطانيا أو روسيا هي القوة الفعلية التي تحكم العالم،
لكن في الحقيقة لا يوجد غير عائلة واحدة
هي من تتحكم بمصير العالم سياسيا واقتصاديا
بل وحتى عسكريا
وهذه العائلة ليست إلا عائلة روتشيلد،،،
..والى هنا تنتهي رحلتنا لهذا الفيديو
لاتنسى الاعجاب با الفيديو